eigentlich ist es schon krass nur wenige
minuten fußweg von ihrer wohnung
entfernt den coup ist einfach offene
drogenszene ansehen jetzt sogar größte
offene drogenszene von schwitzen
vier tage lang bin ich tauchte der
drogenszene vom stadtgarten cool mit
flock was und wer verbirgt sich hinter
den attacken charles zweiter dhs
anzuschließen da das gericht gar nicht
so wirklich und plötzlich
wirst du dich zu mit denen
[Musik]
ich selber habe nur berührungspunkt
mitterrand am anfang vor dem da kann
ihnen angst ob ihr mit trauer zum in the
park in
halle wo wenn wir darüber geredet über
die starke dynamik seit wann einfach
nicht mehr es ist noch hell wie es darf
und dann irgendwie habe ich
es nicht gesteht sondern dienen auch
sagen kann
das konfliktgebiet komisch überlegt und
deshalb
legen wir mit dem ganzen sicher ob das
wirklich sinn machen oder nicht
wahlgang vom startgatter bin ich sofort
angesprochen worden
schon seit 40 jahren szenen konzipiert
ab und zu halloween und wilde kind werde
weil sie angst dass ich dabei bin wenn
ich sehr genau und medina was willst du
machen
wenn sich wirtschaft und sport
wenn ein autohersteller und kam oder ob
damit der fisch frank schwer war die
schönste frau und der
bassist mini mini mini angst zeigen was
sie schon setzen das technologisch tue
ich auch nicht so blöd ja und das ist
der q7 qualität und hätte ausgrabung
einer
vorweg und technikern saison als ich nur
dass die teile so einfach viel besser es
viel kohle den rhein oder wo einfach
eklig ist mir zu geschafft werden aber
die kids nicht viel unterschied zu
vielen frage habt ihr jetzt auch nicht
viel die meisten sind eigentlich
pazifik und verbünde sind alle pazifik
pfiffige europa die
scherfeder schluss heißt die figur danke
vielmals
käufer im emmental
hätten wir jetzt angst nur irgendwer
will ihr seid ja so schlimm real ist und
ich nicht
vielleicht
ist es seine sicht für richtig dass
nicht unbedingt die richtige das findet
der user wenn ihr wirklich werden aber
verfügt hat kühl mit kamerun allem
besser nicht
lustig schon zum stadtbild limacher vor
dem titel eine ganz kühl dass sie mir
gehbehinderten dass der britische pfund
mit dem es
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das lied öffentlichem und dem start
immer wieder in den medien es herrsche
ein aggressiveres stimmig sie dem küsse
drogen werden gehört man aber bald
könnte die offene drogenszene
verschwinden politik will er bis machen
konsum ist seit langem entspreche
stadt chur finanziert außerdem
streetworker
sie dafür wie eine für ihre natur statt
in szene begleiten
klassische texte
sind unterwegs zum freien
überlebenshilfe
dir
und regelmäßig sozialarbeiter wo den
stadtpark aber auch nachbarn rufen zu
können
[Musik]
ja denn alle der
verkehrshelfer
termine valley und ihres team machen 26
war und ist stark
vor die medien nach jedem dienst tun hat
ist die passion also mit nur eines
nebenlagers depeschen vollständig sind
mit einer sache umso mitnehmen sind zum
beispiel die safe boxen
kann ist das ist super sprit material
und hat alkohol und das umso buch das
das man braucht wenn man interviews
konsumiert dass mein sohn klinikapotheke
was mein mann und behandlung
was man auch in tennessee street weg die
rechte die er ab
ja das ist der verteiler man ab und zu
mal gerettet und fragte hast meine erste
geh denken ein vorteil
ist dass man
ihn brauche selber nimmer aber mit der
zigarette findet trotzdem der berlinpass
wie einfach ein opel omega
frustriert ist einfach mega auf braucht
ist ein sehr geübter
station sind von mir so absehbar heißt
sie erkennen wie es auch bei mir kommen
einfach nicht skepsis schon deutlich
größer natürlich abflug schaffen wir mit
der van dyck seinen hut zu nehmen das
ist schon und zusätzliche
recht ruhig da eigentlich so die führung
privat mehr in der stadt bad säckingen
komisch überrascht berichtet
also gerne perspektive ist nicht
berechtigt aber ich verstand ist also
ich kenne selber viel liebe ihres lebens
burg und einen score ruf gottes sind das
sind ja geschichte über das strafbar
über von generation zu generation wie
befreit werden wo vielfachen immer
hinterfragt werden es ist einfach so
stark im kommen
ja ich hab jetzt
stark
und seine noch immer
befindet und mir redet wo denn
ja sie flott fehlen auch hat
wir sind denen
stimmige park entspannt so 15 lüken dem
einer ecke von park der ashley
stammgäste termine hat sony music oder
102 aber unterschiedlich regelmäßige
paar können dass das die größte offene
drogenszene foto schwitzig das war
übrigens nippel egger in vielen der
anderen städte würden so grob jährige
aber mit hunden ermittlung sind so total
abgelenkt dass ducati nachfrage und
videos sind jetzt ja auch relativ viel
liegt wirklich am konsum eric sie wenn
es nötig wird der fokus auf
das natürlich schon dass sie haben
konsumiere sind mir zeitpunkt sind
rechtlich seehofer ja
normale park der führhand finden sich
nicht alle sind und konsumiere vor mir
scheißegal
was ist das
sprit sexy übrigens kein einziger die
meisten rauchen die kleine wiesensteiger
base kokain und kocht mit ammoniak dass
sich im moment die gängigste drogenszene
und sich auch viele junge leute im park
heroin sergio somma vor anderen drogen
das ist mein erster besuch im stadtpark
bilanz durchzogen sind wirklich weile
mit mir oder ich kann sagen das sieht
auch verstorben und sega will wer will
schon über seine drogensucht im
fernsehen vor dem buch
zwischen innovationen trauen aufbau war
so interessant sie ist plötzlich um die
mittagszeit sind zwei touristen aus
lausanne mit der pizza in akko uns in
abkaufte von natalie
stammgästen stadt gab das sind so
und da natürlich dass mir wirklich etwas
dollar auf
und ja das bewegt wenn man vor allem
über die weiß dass der titel ist kann
man locker energie
und man wird nicht besser
nächstes ziel wird finden wo mir redet
und ehrlichkeit luft er ist sie 30 jahre
die szenen unterwegs und er kommt
täglich dorna
falken einfach
denn so wir haben immer so
wenn ich innerhalb der intent antreffen
und damit dem rechnung tragen
wir sind viel musik ertönte als honig
come together oder kinofilmen grund zu
mir das hat auch viel strecke zwischen
diener des gleichen problems gordon und
drogen ums geld benötigt zahlt dann gibt
es zwischen ihnen also meine pizza
war das leckere aber das schneebedeckte
ich das ist verschieden
er meint die offene drogenszene gewiss
kein konsum rum geht wie in anderen
steckt er wirklich so ungeschützt darum
wünsche
so neuer tag neues glück hat
also nicht unbedingt nördlichste tag zum
in einem park hänge nämlich spannend
wäre das
klasse menschen erzeugen wir
respektieren
das funktional nutzungen wie die rede
auch mit tritt wieder fest
luther sie nervös durchsuchen sogar noch
kleiner base steilen wo hinten können
auf der bode kaya krass
raucher verbessere ist förderer als
schnupfer von kokain der wirkstoff
gelangt innerhalb von sekunden in
blutbahn und der konsum kann zu einer
schwere psychische abhängigkeit für das
sei
leider für sie lebte fleisch von base
nur wenige minuten und deshalb sind alle
stress zum zum nächsten fleisch
und klinische kostet aktuell 10 ein
großer 20 und übrigens
property dem moment graz nicht mehr sie
leben da recht auf vertrauen mir
inzwischen besser sie denkt hätte
die einzige wohnung sind polizei mit
einer rechnen jeden moment aber jetzt
gefühl in der einzig oder denkt
drogendealer laden mich sogar zu ihnen
heim
und plötzlich stand ich meine
lehrerzimmer mit viel platz zum 6 5 doch
die wochen für ihre kunden im
stadtgarten und vor allem für sie sprach
henry übrigens noch gesprochen
ducati die lief locker zweiter kaster
gewinn machen allein wenn jetzt drei war
dann wird mir bitte bis grün machen
dadurch dass wir zweiter sind keine
chance will daniel sterner zum raucher
und dann sind da noch mal die rauchend
ich sage jetzt mal die rauchen am tag
die wo viel rauchen traf und der 215 zug
am tag mehr brauchen alle zehn minuten
ein dezember betrug stellt aber wie lang
ist ganz bei chelsea fan aktion fünf
minuten will auto trug so hoch ist der
sportback der angst mir geantwortet oder
bola angst aber respekt weil das
alles doch nicht vom studierender bis
zum obdachloser visa war wirklich alles
das ist kein klischee ist es den
anschein als to space basic so wenn
einmal probiert beschaffe fasziniert und
vom charakter her wir werden zu betonen
herz also zu betonblock durstgefühl mehr
anteil den andere heinz viel gefühl denn
sitzung noch auf länder- und wenn du
genau die abg andré sind wirklich die
tuner für einsteiger aber stärker
dialogen die toxischen blick der denkt
nur genau will der das zeugs wegnehmen
wie hätte ich das ganze denn entwickler
die die letzte jahr im stadtpark szene
musikgemeinschaft sie jetzt lockt jeder
nur genau wie der andere kann von ihnen
absterben jede lok zu seinem vorteil
jede lockt kollege rechte kollege kämen
zukunft schneider für den zug
der stadtpark der beste somit in der
garderobe
und das woher wo sie nicht stören ich
weiß noch nicht es geht los ist reese
geordnet sind mehr stören er mit mir
machen der mutter bis ihr könnt ihn und
nanni seinem schlag gang am meter können
sie am mittag heimatlied da passiert mir
wird die denic stück von der lügner
hier fühlen sich gestört jetzt sogar
froh wenn er mal noch marina kommend
wildpark ich egal wie er fühlen denn
hoffnungsvoll ja wenn das nicht stimmt
dann kann das gemüse wenn ihm eine im
ersten nur genau dass der macher von
jetzt mache ob als viele oder als
süchtiger also bei die täter dann würden
wir schüsse das ist ja die ganze zeit
nur dem zug seidler gesagt und jan oder
im zug
ich bin total überrascht von der
offenheit von der offensichtlichkeit vor
der offenen drogenszene
[Musik]
polizei das problem zu migrieren wie
kann das sie dass sie da nicht macht es
ist ja illegal ist so macht man das
nicht vorgelegen
kanton die stadtpolizei
regelmäßigen statt
ich
bin in denen wenige tag auch mit drucker
dealerin kontakt koordiniert das mit
abermals den druck
sogar dir sehr sind und und und hat
nichts gemerkt hätte dass das wird wohl
eine sie und das hat mir mega überrascht
dass das so
offensichtlich ist
er starb polizei
verständigt da bietet das ganze nicht
funktionieren oder
gehen
gleich dahinter kommt
ich glaube da und die schlüsse
dank
der
stabilen sie was sehr interessante frage
ist
und ich sie noch in eine schlucht
und andere geschichte erzählt als alle
anderen bis jetzt da das ist total show
werdet die fahrt kann zur und erika also
das wohl nicht viele tankstellen das hat
felix es ist der besuch an der
tagesordnung ist aber brutale sache
könnte dass er definitiv
nie trainiert mit dem weg der droge auf
die straße
[Applaus]
jetzt
gehören bischofsstab
zeige wolle das video übernachteten
obdachlos sind cool für mich
unvorstellbar für ihn ist es hat die
realität sie
vor zwölf jahren der us-wirtschaft im
unterland spiele verloren und dennis
berk abgang job verloren honig weg ich
drücke ihnen kunst also damals eine
chronik und an ihrer person braucht ja
genau dass das buch in immer von der
bühne los zum glück kann auch die
substitution nicht
aber sicher
besser das ist
[Musik]
fast so
lang zu schließen das wäre ich gar nicht
so beweglich und plötzlich reden
lässt nichts mit denen
auf dvd box wo und desto vor hitze
etwas wetten
dass behinderte welt sind das ist groß
und es im winter auch
keine oder wenige
und den
12 wir können nur vergeben im senat ist
bekannt
dafür habe ich werde meinen beitrag
komische zum nachhinein über noten so
komisch romantikerin extrem 2 gegen die
recht vor der welt
na ja geht immer noch etwas
eingeschlafen vom board also da haben
wir
wirklich immer nur von einer papiertüte
hat braucht und den ausgleich der
schlafsack
der klinik
zehn jahre ist
ja aber hebräisch in stress geldes
konnte in regensburg der polizei haben
und steht für oben über machen und dann
muss jeder weg
es wird die schau die als der person
selber zum schaffen oder wohnungssuche
war sowieso klar aber sie haben uns
nicht
hast dich niemand ist mit absicht oder
aus faulheit und wieder los zu schlafen
ist dass in dem was in dieser geschichte
und schicksal behindert und
ja heute schwierig sagt folger
vor zwölf york sei dass sie irgendwann
einmal
hertie druck und immer geschweige denn
honig oder obdachlos bin hätte ich das
ist niemals dass wir die unmögliche
passiert
passiert ist
funktioniert
ja jetzt schon kölner aber recht und
sami
k
ich kann schon das restaurant liegt
unter dem motto das westliche das
problem
dass viele bliebe aber das sei irgendwie
auch nichtwähler ja auch so scheint sie
hat ja jetzt so eine kugel zu wenig sind
die schafe im sozialamt ja erwartet aber
darauf anders formulieren das
usc team immer wieder in stuttgart das
soziale umfeld andere kontakt helga
grömer wirklich
so viel staat gar der dritte frau mit
iranischer sparen und geräte die die
letzte decke
wie findest du sagen dass sich für ihn
stark macht
ich finde das gut
also ich finds gottes müssen durch man
darf ihnen laufend film macht ohne dass
die strokes und
man merkt dass dies interessiert also
bestimmt nach honig will einen film
machen sondern schafft gegangen und es
interessiert mich wirklich also also
letzte schulklasse nach
hat es wurde shrek wunderschöne geworden
weiß der kollege dann live in big love
von adele wissen was mit all denen sind
oder dass man über labels sind
stehen wir vor dem zoo letzte mal war
das notebook kommt heute kein
unterricht stattfand wie die was das
bedeutet er die ehre
charles zweiter die
arminia ist so taxi und ja ich kenne das
alles so
reduzierte es ist ja so viel verändert
wenn luxe kugel wäre richter zudem
fehlen jeglicher die größte scheiß
offenen drogenszene das watched ein buch
das am meisten dass ein süßes dass sie
mitnehmen so denkt vor dem film hat das
ist nichts gefährliches mir kein böser
mensch sind
mailand dann in ruhe so lang sind
ordentlich merian anhören wenn
servicewüste weltraumflug
und
es sind jetzt zwei wochen vergangen mit
der frau und
miteinander geredet haben ja ich mir
schon alles bliebe und was für alle
bleiben ich das alles sei technisch dass
der stadtpark es sei für sich nachteil
hat unfreiwillig besucht bestimmt young
in der sie immer wieder details
zum
wasser frage ist
konsum ja wenn der grund heißt es
funktionieren das nächste thema aber sie
liefert uns ja das ist oft sehr stumpf
und deshalb glaube nicht dass alle
läufer verschwinden nur wer genau
hinzugucken
aber was immer ist sie sind friedlich
ich bin jetzt ein parkdeck taxi und
immer sind es eigentlich auch wenn ihr
gehörten das wirklich anders kann sie
dass es die brutal kann sie wenn's um
geld und um die gott
und dusko hocker oder was man stütze dem
ganzen dauer chips mit kommentar ich
freue mich schon so mit dir diskutier